surprising news appeared an artist spent
a 100 hours creating something truly
incredible for a book cover image
unfortunately only to be accused having
used an AI however when I looked at this
my first thought was that this looks way
too good for an AI image in
2023 why is that well look there is so
much detail in this image no
state-of-the-art text to image AI system
can match it the resolution of this
image the number of pixels are just too
high until now dear fellow Scholars this
is 2minute papers with Dr Caro now
previous techniques already exist to
increase the resolution of input images
or even videos this is what we call
upscaling or super resolution and it is
starting to appear in video games and in
some cases it already runs in real time
so so why not apply it to these AI me
photos that should be easier than video
right well not quite you see super
resolution means that we introduce new
information into an image and this new
information is unfortunately not always
what should be there for instance text
can easily get mangled in video games or
if we have a stationary photo that we
would like to frame it better not have
artifacts like this right so is all hope
lost for high resolution images that was
what I thought until I saw the news from
mid Journey a popular text to image AI
system which can now create incredibly
detailed high resolution images with a
recent update and the results are truly
insane how does it work well you first
generate a lower resolution image these
are pretty good however when we start
zooming in we start to see the limits of
this resolution but then hold on to your
papers fellow Scholars because we can
ask it to perform 4X super resolution
and then this
happens there is just so much more
detail in these images I am completely
stunned wow this seems like years and
years of progress and it just dropped a
few days ago in an update like nothing
had happened now other super resolution
or image upscaling systems also exist in
fact they are in abundance today we have
so many options however this kind of
quality is beyond what I have seen from
other Solutions out there according to
other users it is perhaps matched only
by the gigapixel AI system I gave it a
brief try and did not have too much luck
with it so far it is also a standalone
application which is not necessary when
it is built right into the text to image
AI for me so far this workflow has been
unmatched and it just delivers over and
over again my opinion is that these
techniques are deceivingly useful you
see you may often have an image that is
a regular photograph or an AI generated
work where you love the image but the
framing is not quite perfect and you
would only like to use one small part of
it however when you do that you take the
parts that you like and suddenly there
are just not enough details for this
image to stand on its own and in these
cases these super resolution techniques
can make or break that image loving it
now not even this technique is perfect
not even close in some cases excessive
smoothing happens which is quite curious
look you would think that this is the
low resolution image and this is the
upscaled but that is not the case due to
this smoothing details are not only
added to the image but some can even
disappear in the process but in return
the overall image and the edges of the
objects are way sharper so there are
cases where this is a tradeoff that we
have to consider and my goodness through
the power of AI research today everyone
can experience the amazing feeling of
their artistic ideas coming to life
there are already systems that even work
on the phone in your pocket wow and to
think that text to video also exist just
imagine that soon this is what will
happen to videos 2 soon everyone will be
able to become a movie director for at a
small small cost and then over time all
this will be free for all of us what a
time to be alive we are sponsored by
weights and biases experiment tracking
model evaluation and production
monitoring for your deep learning
products and llm apps it is the best
everyone is using it try it out now at
wnb me/ papers or click the link in the
description below